you know what game is super racist and  violent chess  it's the blacks versus the ones the  whites are the aggressors  it's actually a good point we gotta  change the color of Chester like uh uh  like blue and light blue damn well  better because it really indicates like  Middle Eastern Conference  changes to red to blue as Dennis the  Bloods versus the Crips no no you do  blue and light blue everybody's blue but  you can tell them apart right right or  you just do numbers like the ones and  the twos no no no no one side is the a  side and the side is the one side that  way no one's beneath each other and no  one's a different color you got a board  full of all the same color pieces  man it's crazy